un forzado paso atrás la población de
valhondo al sur de guatemala se
convirtió en un punto muerto para la
caravana de migrantes que partió desde
honduras el viernes buscando llegar a
eeuu
con presencia de la policía militar la
caravana fue dispersada para reabrir el
tránsito de la carretera y bloquear el
paso de unas 4000 personas que
permaneciendo en total libras ocho mil
que se estima comenzaron el viaje el fin
de semana maltratado de perra mediante
para su país no hay mucho esto
va donde se encuentra sólo 55 kilómetros
de la frontera sur con honduras es
todavía el comienzo de un largo viaje
que ya en guatemala se enfrenta a la
oposición del gobierno evitar que
continúen en su trayectoria para llegar
la frontera mexicana donde no se les
dejara pasar y donde se podrá sí sí si
no lo evitamos podemos tener una
potencial crisis humanitaria de gran
escala méxico ya ha desplegado a su
guardia nacional en chiapas su frontera
con guatemala su presidente andrés
manuel lópez obrador le recordó a su
homólogo electo de estados unidos joe
biden su promesa de campaña de realizar
una reforma migratoria según la agencia
ap ese plan incluiría un plazo de ocho
años para
a los 11 millones de personas que viven
en la unión americana sin definir su
estatus migratorio